all right in this video we're talking
about the document-based question or DBQ
section on the AP u.s. History exam now
this is one of two main essays that are
on the exam one is based on documents
that are provided to you and the other
is based on your own knowledge of the
subject so you'll get fifty five minutes
to do this portion of the exam and it's
generally recommended that you spend
about 15 of those minutes planning your
answer and about 40 of those minutes
actually writing your answer now your
mileage might differ you might find that
you're someone who wants to spend a
little bit more time planning or you're
somebody who can plan really fast and
write well in any event you want to go
in with a plan about how much time
you're going to spend on each part so
you don't get surprised at the end of
the period that you still have a couple
paragraphs left to right but you're out
of time so for the DBQ section you're
going to get a question that asks you to
analyze changes or continuities over
time something that really gets at the
heart of how things in history change
over time so unlike the short answer
questions which are very sort of
specific about one period in time this
is asking you to take a broader look at
US history and write an essay about one
of its major themes alright let's take a
look at this question analyze major
changes and continuities in the social
and economic experiences of
african-americans who migrated from the
south to urban areas in the north in the
period 1910 to 1930 alright well that
gives us a lot of information about the
kinds of things we should concentrate on
so first we're looking at social history
and economic history we're looking at
African Americans and we're looking at
this migration pattern so this is the
period of the
migration as they would say when many
african-americans who lived in the South
moved to the north for new factory jobs
in this time period which certainly
included World War one and you can see
from the time frame that we're talking
about a fairly early 20th century time
period ending in 1930 so you don't want
to be talking about the experiences of
African Americans in the Great
Depression or in World War two or in the
civil rights movement because that's
much later now you might be able to end
on a note that shows your knowledge of
what's to come but really for the meat
of this essay you want to stick to the
time period in question to answer this
we're going to want to write an essay
and at the very least I would go for
your kind of standard five paragraph
essay where you have an introductory
statement introduction which includes
the strong thesis statement and we'll
get to how to write one of those soon
and then three paragraphs of body text
each that is trying to prove a point
brought up in its topic sentence and a
conclusion which wraps up what you've
said and ties it up with a bow now to do
this you're going to have to consider
and analyze about seven to nine primary
documents which are provided for you by
the exam and you should include all or
maybe all but one of those primary
documents in your answer now you don't
have to go into detail about all of them
but you should include analysis of some
of the arguments some of the biases and
some of the larger ideas behind some of
those documents and you should also be
prepared to give some outside
information that shows that you really
know the material and can give context
to it
all right so that's what these questions
are about and how you should go about
answering them in the next video we'll
start looking at primary documents and
getting ready to make a thesis statement